a speedy recovery now but it shouldn't
be as a surprise
a new abc poll just came out this
morning
three out of four americans doubt that
president trump
took the threat of covert 19
seriously enough to his health and to
the american people's health
and why might they think that well look
at this super spreader photo
this is amy coney barrett's
uh ceremony at the white house loads of
people sitting very closely together for
long periods of time
with no masks most of them in fact
when they went inside they were
encouraged to take off their masks even
though being inside is more damaging
than being outside
so we're here today to to to
talk about two people who have to take
kovid
seriously more seriously and act on it
the first is mitch mcconnell mitch
mcconnell seems to be
jamming through the hearings on
amy coney barrett even though
three senators have coveted
even though he has said it's not safe
for the senate to meet in session
but it's okay to have the hearings it
makes no sense
if it's not safe for the senate to meet
in session
it's not safe for the hearings to go
forward
and the idea of having virtual hearings
where no one is with the witness
for the highest court in the land for a
life appointment that would have such
effect
on people's lives makes no sense
a virtual hearing is virtually no
hearing
at all you need to be with the witness
and have direct cross cross uh
questions and back and forth with them
and we all know
the nominee this supreme court
nomination
affects people's health care and their
protection
with pre-existing conditions helps
stands for preserving or eliminating a
woman's right to choose
stands for keeping worker rights strong
voter rights strong lbgtq rights straw
so for mitch mcconnell to go ahead with
the hearing
endangers the safety not only of
senators
but of staff who work diligently on the
hill
and they ought to be delayed there is no
reason on god's green earth why these
shouldn't be delayed other than an
effort
to rush a witness through in an
inadequate hearing
where people can't even see the witness
face to face
so we are demanding today along with
millions of americans and many many
groups
that the hearings be postponed if
mcconnell believes they should be
postponed in the senate
they should be postponed at the hearing
level
the second point is the president we
need full transparency we all know the
president's cavalier attitude
towards covet towards masks towards
social distancing
has endangered many people including
himself
as again this picture shows but it
happened over
and over and over again so now
at the very minimum we need full
transparency
we need to know exactly the level of the
president's health we have to know who
else got covered
how severely they have it that applies
to the senators that applies to the
workers in the white house and all the
top level people at the white house
when you don't have full transparency
when there's cover-ups
contradictory statements even lying
about something as vital to the nation's
security as the president's health
the nation is severely endangered
we know that president trump has a
pension for not telling the truth
but when it comes to something as vital
as this
the health of the president the health
of the people around him
we need to know the whole truth and
nothing but the truth
or as joe friday said just the facts
just the facts ma'am no cover-up no
spinning
no half-truths the whole story
and we're calling on the president to
start being truthful
fully and holy truthful about his
condition
and the condition of all those around
him leaving anything out angelo
no okay those are the two issues
questions on the these two subjects
senator what
procedural options would you have in
your disposal that you didn't have
before because of
illnesses within the republican party
well they can still go ahead with the
hearings whether the senate meets or not
hearings can occur independent of the
senate if they can occur when the senate
is out of session
we will have many more procedural
options when it comes to a vote in the
senate committee
and a vote on the floor and we will use
every tool in the tool box
to delay and not have the votes
occur
well we're going to talk to that over
but we're going to use every procedural
tool that we can
first job delay these hearings we can't
force the delay
but public pressure on the senators both
who have coven and who don't
we should be delaying these hearings so
we can have a full and fair hearing
not something over zoomed that doesn't
measure up
when you have the most important
appointment that the senate makes for a
lifetime
mcconnell repeatedly that all senators
get tested and all our staffs get tested
and so far he has not gone along with it
and i think he is very very wrong
thank you everybody have a good day
yeah i will your dog have a mask
is that your dog mask or a person that
you're holding
person mask okay okay thank you
everybody
angelo give me the picture i'll hold it
up here
here you go